hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another sundance 2022
interview i've got the team behind duel
with me hello
congratulations this was uh one heck of
a ride thank you
thank you you're pretty proud so with a
festival movie i must start here riley
can you give us a synopsis of duel for
the folks out there who are not aware of
your movie just yet yeah surprisingly
i'm not good at talking about this movie
yet but uh i'll try my best it's a duel
follows sarah who finds out she's
dying from a terminal disease and in
this alternate sort of reality she's
able to have herself cloned so that her
family doesn't have to miss her but
after a year or so of her living with
this clone and the clone learning how to
be her and then kind of evolving into
her own person uh she goes into
remission and in this arbitrary sort of
way there can't be two of you existing
at the same time so she has to duel her
clone to the death to figure out who
continues to be safe so i wouldn't be
surprised if you've heard this already
but the movie obviously gives me black
mirror vibes and basically we've hit a
point where literally any story with a
futuristic technology as compared to
black mirror so i don't know if you
dealt with this in the pitching stage
but i wonder if a comparison like that
can help you and help someone understand
and get behind your vision or if that
kind of situation is more like
if it's more beneficial to be like no
this is this is my own thing that's
completely different i think i'm pretty
fortunate and that i've been able to
this is my third feature so i've got
sort of a track record and people can go
back and watch faults or the art of
self-defense and see that maybe if
something on paper reads a certain way
they know that there might be a little
twist on that uh or that subversion on
that expectation of what that plot would
give you um so
xyz who ended up making the movie were
pretty great uh reddit
said we want to do this and we love your
stuff and like let's just make your
movie as opposed to some of the people
that i met with before who were either
not able to totally jive with it or
wanted to make a lot of changes to uh
the where it went uh so it was kind of a
match made in heaven i didn't didn't
really have to pull uh xyz around or or
ask them too much they kind of just let
me do what i wanted to do just because
now it's making me curious are you
allowed to share anything about where
you know another individual wanted it to
go instead of what we get i mean without
saying too much about the plot maybe not
but like
just
little suggestions that that would be
thrown into the conversation like oh
yeah and then that like this could
happen and then me on the phone being
like i'm never gonna do that so i'm just
not gonna i'm gonna act like i just
didn't hear what they said and continue
to keep that that's always a good and
wait that's such a funny response to
that i'll also tell you exactly what
that was
it's nothing it's nothing against other
producers it's just that if i'm going to
make something
that i want to make like i i just i know
what i want it to be already and the
fact that the producers who ended up
making the film saw eye to eye with me
we didn't have to butt heads on
literally anything it was the easiest
working relationship ever and they
watched the movie gave me three notes
and i took one of them and then the
movie's the movie i love hearing that
you stuck to your vision i can't imagine
this playing out any other way
for all of you now yet another thing i'm
sure you're going to hear a lot but you
know i do love movies that
make me consider what i would do in a
particular situation and you know it's a
little morbid here but if this
technology did exist would you actually
use it
oh god would i
i mean because it's creepy like think
about that reality for a second yeah
like
you have another version of yourself
that's like a little bit off and maybe
glitchy walking around after you're dead
like
we're not doing that
i think if you watch if you watch the
infomercial that's in the movie that
sells you on the idea of it i don't
think you're gonna do it yeah
i don't know anybody would i would use
it as a prank
for when i'm dead and it would make an
appearance at my funeral but then it
would need to shut down and power down
and never come to life again
yeah i would leave it up to my you know
my wife and kids i think you know if
they're like if they wanted a a copy of
me okay that's that's their decision i
wouldn't want one
you wouldn't want a copy of yourself
like a hangover one like you know when
i'm hungover and not a great like
husband or father i was just like i pull
in the i pull out the bueller point two
at the closet and be like all right i'll
turn you on now which one of your voices
i feel like you just got the right
answer that's what these should be used
for
just the hangovers yeah okay i want to
change my answer yeah um
riley thinking thinking about that so
the movie doesn't necessarily need this
but when i get obsessed with the concept
i want to know everything about it did
you ever work out how the world just in
general felt about this technology
existing if it was something that if you
chose to use it like it was okay and
just the norm or if it was frowned upon
i think it's the norm but
obviously it's cost prohibitive so not
everyone goes that route but they're
able to sell people on it because of the
the way that they structure the payments
uh i think it's just like accepted and
i had this i wrote like a short story
version of this film before i wrote the
feature
and i got halfway through it which is
like 20 pages
and didn't end up finishing it
but it was really cool to go through the
process that way which i'd never done
before because i filled in because it's
pros you get to have more fun
filling in all these gaps and talking
about the history of things so i had
this like alternate timeline history
that it was developed during the cold
war to like increase the amount of uh
our people in our military uh as like a
build-up and then they ended up just
like getting rid of
making it to where you could only use it
for these medical situations and i love
that the movie doesn't talk about any of
them like i love that it it
any other movie would explain everything
too much or or have to because like of
the world that you're in whereas in our
kind of tone and and uh the the setting
of the movie and the way that it feels
you can just say it is and then it is
and that was more fun for me
goes against everything you just said
but with that description i kind of want
a whole series or like even an anthology
with this concept where you get to see
how different people react to using it
yeah we we definitely i there was a
producer that asked
like a year or two ago like what the
dual tv show would be like and like you
could do an anthology sort of thing like
this but i also like that when i make
something it kind of just gets to be and
then you move on to the next thing and i
like that duel is just duel it's fair
enough i'm greedy when i find something
that i like though
so karen a very unique opportunity for
you here
i was wondering if there's anything you
discovered about your own craft being in
a scene with yourself and i guess you
know essentially being your own scene
partner in a sense gosh that was a very
unique situation
um that i have done three times in three
different movies
like is that my type casting
i only found that out after the fact too
yeah that's so funny i i guess because i
work in like time travel things or
sci-fi i've met myself along the way um
it's always really strange it's always
slightly off because normally you're so
used to reacting off of the other actor
and i was doing that with the wonderful
actress that we had katharina but then
at the same time i'm still plotting what
i'm going to do with it when i'm filming
my coverage and then i'm trying to react
off of what i'm imagining myself doing
in the future and
it became really strange and trippy
wow
riley i also wanted to ask you a little
bit about the tone that you ran with on
this which is very very specific why did
this particular story necessitate that
kind of dark comedy tinge
well it's not that the story
necessitates it it's that i kind of
can't not do it myself so i've always
said that
like the first short that i ever made
that i don't have online anymore because
i don't like it uh
i don't like it because it's not me it
has no sense of humor i was trying to
play everything straight and it felt
disingenuous it felt like i was trying
to do something that just didn't i don't
know work with the way that i think and
so
uh going forward i kind of vowed to
myself that i was only going to ever
make things that felt like me and that
tends to be the starkly comedic space
and and i felt like uh you've seen going
back to like move their shows that are
like this this sort of theme or we've
seen clone movies before swan song came
out last year with similar sort of start
of a premise um i like that the tone is
what makes ours different and i feel
like it's it's what makes it worth
watching and exploring even though you
may have seen something along these
lines before
you're not going to see where it goes
and you're not going to expect how it
feels
i like that you stick to it it's why i
keep coming back to your movies they're
so specifically you yeah i mean it
i don't want to get into any spoilers
but this this scene feels kind of safe
to talk about so karen and beulah one
moment that sticks out in my mind is
when they have the conversation about
sarah's condition being terminal and you
know i'm watching a scene like that and
i'm thinking that if i were one of you
every bone in my body would be saying go
so big emotionally here so
what was it like conveying that
information in a way that matters but
also making sure that it matched that
tone that riley just described
um i think there's a genius of riley
like because i came in going
man i'm gonna try some acting stuff and
riley was just like
nah
just
say the words how they are and it was so
like tough me as a like
it was such a challenge because i didn't
know i told writers that i'm not good at
comedy i'm scared of comedy i'm scared
of everything but can you just like i'm
gonna trust that what you're telling me
is true
and and and it was like you he just said
just say the line be you're enough just
like how he makes his film he's just
like he's enough there's no
extra thing needed he just does it the
way
he would do it and he you just said just
say the words like you would say in an
american exit
and that that was a true
that was definitely a tricky scene for
me as a director too because like you
said you're conveying this information
to somebody that they're dying
and i wanted the movie despite the tone
and the the stylization of the delivery
to still feel grounded and still feel
relatable which is a very
hard tight rope to walk
and that scene particularly could go
melodramatic very easy easily or super
dramatic and not either of those
versions don't necessarily fit in the
world of this movie
and to be his credit he just kind of
like we went through it a few times in
his living room uh in his apartment that
we were staying he was staying in in
finland and we shot it on an iphone and
kind of just did it a few times and felt
it out and the last one was this one
where it just kind of like released it a
bit and kind of just said it to her and
was just i'm gonna give you this
information as if he's telling her about
his day and that's the scene that ended
up or the tape that ended up in the
movie and it's it's one that i love that
is actually one of the hardest things is
to just
talk uh in a matter-of-fact way and i
feel like i'm a performer who almost
hides behind emotion i'm kind of like
oh yeah it's easier if i'm like crying
or something to grab onto but to simply
talk is one of the more exposing ways to
act and that's why this was such an
amazing challenge as a movie
job very well done in that respect uh
aaron let's talk trent now again
backstory obsessed did you ever work out
how he became an expert in training
people for duels
um i you know he's just i had you know
many conversations with riley he's that
is just his his world you know he
he pretty much lives at his gym you know
riley's like just imagine him just his
mattresses we had a couch in the back
that you never really see but it's there
yeah we assumed he probably just right
yeah he just sleeps on and you know he
obviously takes it very seriously and um
so yeah there's a it's a huge
responsible ability to take on because
he's training someone
it's a life and death sort of situation
and um
and uh thank you um
i'm like yeah so it's just uh you know
it's a life and death situation and you
know so he's very proud of that um but
um but yeah you know uh
he he lives and breathes it and so um
yeah are there any fun little easter
eggs in addition to the couch on that
set you know like random weapons on the
wall or something like that that people
should look out for
yeah there was a lot there's a lot of
stacks on the wall or something there
were so many weapons on the wall
there was one easter egg that didn't
make it on camera so like i there's the
fake movie that we have in the movie
that she watches and trent had a stack
of all his burned dvds like i just
they're all burned like he ripped them
from probably kazaa or something like
that like they're whatever the version
of that was in this world and he uh he
i think i made up a bunch of fake movie
titles and then i put mandy too so my
friend panos and aaron steward-ons movie
uh would live in the world some way in
some way but uh it never made it on
camera so mandy too
i'll have to use that at some point oh
yeah that makes me incredibly happy i
love mandy
um
i have to let you guys go but before i'm
gonna put out a request that you should
release the clip of your dance scene
and you should get people to recreate
the
dance tick-tock
yeah once once it's like literally
like hours of youtube training to dance
that dance scene was so funny because
our instructor
who is teaching us the dance couldn't
stop
herself from laughing at us like at them
like ha ha like at us because she's like
well it's funny because you're trying
and it's yeah she's like yeah so funny
when you concentrate so hard
but yeah we're taking we're trying to
take ourselves seriously here um but
yeah uh
the fins are very particular people and
we love them i love them so much she's
actually to be honest she's the best
she's the best she's so needed to be
locked up yeah
i enjoyed being laughing yeah
all right i gotta let you guys go you
have a busy day you're celebrating today
i gotta circle back so eventually we
could talk spoilers at a point but
congratulations
everybody out there keep an eye out for
duel thank you thank you
bye
you